MALE SPEAKER: We've all heard
the stories about the poor
woman in the third world who
gets a loan for $50 and buys a
sewing machine and lifts her
family out of poverty.
And who wouldn't love
that story?
We all love it.
And so about 20 years ago, a lot
of money started flooding
into this sector.
And maybe you wonder
where it all goes.
So Hugh Sinclair is here today
to tell us where it goes.
Hugh's stayed in some of the
worst hotels on the planet,
eaten some of the worst food on
the planet, including the
porcupine smoothie.
Make sure and ask him
about that one.
So he spent about 10 years in
places like Mozambique, and
Mexico, and Lagos, Nigeria,
right next to the building
where all those Nigerian princes
live, and gotten in
for a bit of trouble by telling
the truth about where
the money actually goes and
what happens to it.
For instance, ask
him about Kiva.
He has some good stories
about that.
So without further ado--
I always love saying that--
please welcome Hugh Sinclair.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH SINCLAIR: Lovely.
Thank you very much.
Great honor to be in the
Google headquarters.
Heard a lot about it.
Lightning introduction.
I mean, first of all, how
familiar are people with
microfinance?
You all vaguely know
what it is.
Has anyone done any investments
in microfinance,
in Kiva, those sorts
of things, funds?
Yeah, OK.
So this is probably going
to be kind of sobering.
I'm an economist originally, and
former investment banker.
I have an MBA from IESE Business
School in Barcelona.
And I was, I believe, the
last employee at Enron.
I joined two weeks before
it collapsed.
So it's either totally
my fault or
nothing to do with me.
I'll leave it up to
you to decide.
So I then became a
bit disillusioned
with mainstream finance.
You know, it wasn't
going that well.
This was 10 years ago.
Let's try something new.
I'd only ever really worked as
an economist and in banking.
So I figured, let's
do microfinances.
It's finance-related,
it's technical, all
this sort of stuff.
But hopefully I can
have an impact.
So I sort of went into the
sector of this naive idea of,
you know, let's try
and help the poor.
So during this decade, I think
I spent 8 of the 10 years
living in developing
countries.
So I'm not one of these people
who live in DC and fly to some
far-flung nation, take a couple
of photos, and then say
that I'm working
on development.
I actually live in these
countries to this day.
And I guess the other thing I
need to do as a instruction is
to say I'm a heretic now, thanks
to writing this book.
I'm a whistleblower.
And I'm enjoying all the
benefits of being fired by an
entire industry simultaneously,
which is a
quite unusual feeling.
I'm going to just do a
lightning summary of
microfinance.
We all know what it is, this
idea of the woman with the
goat or the sewing machine.
She gets the $100 loan.
She builds up some business.
And with the income from
that businesses,
she gets out of poverty.
She repays the loan, recycles
the loan to the next person.
Everyone's a winner.
We're all familiar
with this story.
Now, the reality is that it is
actually very, very different.
First of all, it should come as
no surprise that the vast
majority of people are not
a budding Bill Gates
entrepreneur.
It's not so easy to actually
make very high returns in
developing countries when maybe
you have a very limited
education, you're operating in
fiercely competitive markets.
It's actually really,
really difficult.
And it should come as no
surprise that, you know, is
there much evidence of people
building up these huge
enterprises on the back
of a $200 loan?
Absolutely none whatsoever.
How much of the capital isn't
actually invested in the
business at all?
It's very difficult to find
out how much money is used
simply for paying off getting
a loan from one bank to pay
off the next bank to pay off
the next bank to pay
off the next bank.
This sort of recycling of
credit, it's very difficult to
get estimates of that.
It's very difficult to find out
how much microfinance is
actually just spent
on consumption.
There are estimates.
There was an estimate in the
"Harvard Business Review" a
few years ago suggesting it
might be as high as 90% is not
actually going into a
microenterprise at all.
I think that's a bit
on the high side.
But my gut feel is that it's
certainly at least 3/4 of all
microfinance is going nowhere
near a microenterprise.
So of course it's not
having an impact.
It's not going to an enterprise
in the first place.
Then there's been all the recent
cases, particularly in
Andhra Pradesh in India, of
really bad abuses of clients.
There's been 54 suicides so far
which have been blamed by
the Indian government, published
reports just that
this was at the hands of
aggressive money lenders
disguised as microfinance
institutions, basically.
There's been cases of women
forced into prostitution.
And there's been cases of
children being kidnapped as
collateral for loans.
So we're talking, in the worst
cases, some pretty sordid
activities.
But oh, we shouldn't forget,
child labor.
Who do you think is actually
working in these small
microenterprise when they
suddenly have to increase
their production by 500% in
order just to cover the
interest costs?
When you suddenly go from
selling 20 tomatoes to 200
tomatoes, it's labor-intensive.
Where do you get
the labor from?
Your own children.
So there is also now
growing evidence.
There's been a few academic
papers looked into this, that
are suggesting that, actually
microfinance and promoting
this informal economy might
actually be resulting in
children being taken out of
schools to work in what we
call microsweatshops.
And if you think about it, it
would make complete sense that
that happens.
If you walk around one of these
poor markets in some
remote corner of Africa or in
Latin America at 2 o'clock in
the afternoon on a school
day, what do you see?
Kids running around
stacking shelves.
So it's not really surprising
that this happens.
There's also some really
fundamental
problems with the model.
If you work on the supply side
of a market, if you increase
the number of people selling
tomatoes, sure, some of those
tomato vendors might actually
do very well.
But the total number of tomatoes
being sold, the total
demand is not changing.
Microfinance is on
the supply side.
So what about all those people
who are being displaced,
people who used to sell tomatoes
and have now been
driven out of the business?
Because there's only so many
tomatoes for sale.
So that whole aspect-- they call
it job displacement or
crowding out-- is completely
ignored by the
microfinance community.
They only focus on the people
who get the loans.
There's no discussion of the
people who got displaced.
It's like if you're analyzing
a national lottery and you
only interviewed the winners.
You need to talk to the million
people who bought a
ticket and didn't win.
This is just a little thing that
we just quietly forget.
But then, above all, the
academic evidence.
There's been two really
big studies.
David Roodman at the Center for
Global Development in DC
recently summarized it
very succinctly.
He said that the overall impact
of microfinance on
poverty reduction is zero.
And then Maren Duvendack, the
academic funded by the UK
government in Britain, she
analyzed 2,836 academic papers
over the last 30 years and
concluded that microfinance
had no impact on poverty
reduction whatsoever.
And actually, it may have been
a huge waste of time and a
missed opportunity, had we
actually used the money for
something else.
So the literature is really
coming down hard against the
microfinance sector, which
is unfortunate.
So I tried to fix this from the
inside, working in these
institutions, sort of pointing
these things out.
Didn't work.
So I started leaking stories
to media, hoping to attract
some attention.
I actually got a story into
the front page of the "New
York Times." Momentarily
interesting for a few people.
You know, oh, that's cool.
But it's called the rogue
operator argument.
Oh no, there's another
bad one.
Oh, there's a bad one.
But the system, microfinance
overall is good.
But yeah, every now and then,
there's a few exceptions.
That's the way that
it's presented
to the outside world.
So what I decided to do was
actually just write a book and
explain that these are
not isolated cases.
This is an actual systemic
flaw in the entire
microfinance sector.
So that's why I've
now been fired by
everyone in the world.
What's unusual about the book?
I mean, really there's a subtle
shift of focus that
I've tried to do.
There's been other books written
about microfinance.
But this is the first one which
is written by an insider
who's worked, often
to quite high
levels, within the sector.
And it's the first one to
really specifically name
individual people and individual
companies very
clearly, entire total
transparency.
Every single document and
audio recordings, video
footage, emails, every single
supporting document for the
entire book is online.
Anyone can go on to the website
and check it out and
verify these things
for themselves.
Because sometimes you're reading
the book, you're like,
no, I don't believe that it
actually got that bad, or that
someone at that level of
seniority was doing these
sorts of actions.
And all I just say to the reader
is, go to the website.
You want to listen to the
entire phone call?
You can download the
entire call.
The names, nothing is hidden.
AUDIENCE: What's the website?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Oh yeah,
the website's
microfinancetransparency.com.
Yeah, so I detail who's
involved, how they did it, why
they did it, and how they
tried to cover it up.
And given that I was actually
one of the people who did
these things and worked, to some
extent, on the cover-ups,
I have fairly good information
on this.
I didn't just look at the
individuals MFIs, the
individual institutions.
But I tried to explain where
is the money coming from.
Who are the investors?
Who is providing the
money for this?
How much information did they
know when they made these
certain investments?
I look at the role of
the rating agencies.
the regulators.
And then, importantly, the PR
companies, how do they take
this data and how do they spin
it to the world so that we all
sort of think, oh, this is
wonderful, and we open our
wallets and we invest
more money?
My view of the main problem in
the microfinance sector is, in
economics it's referred to as
the principal-agent problem.
You've got money.
And you can't invest it directly
yourself into an
individual microentrepreneur.
So you have to go through
an institution.
I mean, examples in the US are
Grameen Foundation USA,
Calvert Foundation, Kiva,
Deutsche Bank Microcredit
Fund, Citibank, Standard
Chartered.
All these people have
microfinance funds.
Or they facilitate you getting
your money from your pocket to
the poor people.
My basic premise is, how can
we ensure that those
intermediaries are acting in our
best interest and the best
interest of the poor?
In any other area of business,
in any other area of finance,
the principal agent problem
is considered
to be a huge obstacle.
In microfinance, apparently
it doesn't exist.
It is a complete myth.
There's absolutely no reason to
believe that the person who
you trust your money with
when you're trying to do
microfinance investment
is acting
in their best interests.
That is the only thing you
can be truly sure of.
Those do not necessarily match
up with the interests of the
poor or your own interests.
And then what I tried to do is
I tried to provide a roadmap
for people.
So instead of just saying, well,
these are good, these
are bad, what I tried to do is
explain to the reader, OK,
this is how you can go and find
out if the vehicle that
you're using, the intermediary
you're using is good or bad.
This is how you would see a
good institution, a good
microfinance bank
from a bad one.
These are the sorts of questions
you need to ask.
These are the kind of responses
that you've gotta be
listening out for.
And if you get told things--
for example, we don't know
what the interest rate is, we
can't actually tell you what
the interest rate is because
of some technical reason--
these are like big
alarm bells.
Be careful.
So what I tried to do is help
people to be empowered to make
the right decisions.
Because at the end of the day,
there are two groups of people
who are being exploited
in microenterprise.
There's the poor.
And there are you guys, you guys
who believe that you're
doing something useful.
And you trust it.
You have the best intentions
to try and do something to
help the poor.
So in actual fact, you're being
duped just as much as
the woman who signs a contract
and suddenly finds out she's
paying 195% interest a year.
There's two angles to it.
Right, I'm not going
to summarize the
book in any more detail.
What I'm gonna talk about is how
did we get into this mess.
How did we arrive in a situation
where we're making
loans to poor people at 195%
interest and we're believing
that we're helping people
get out of poverty?
I mean, if you think
about it, it's
completely ridiculous, really.
And we sort of think, well, if
this company that is charging
195% interest a year does an IPO
and individual people make
multimillion-dollar packages--
Accion, on a $1 million
investment in the IPO of
Compartamos, made
$270 million.
That's a very, very
decent return.
If you look at what interest
rates the poor are paying--
195% is the maximum rates
in that particular bank.
And no one's putting two and two
together and saying, hmm,
maybe it's the poor people
paying so much interest which
made these people make
so much money.
So how did we get here?
It's actually completely
ridiculous.
It's so against what Muhammad
Yunus originally said.
Let's use affordable
credit to help
people get out of poverty.
It's not happening.
But how did it get this bad?
So I think there are a number
of reasons to explain this.
I think, first of all,
it's the idea.
We love the idea.
It sounds so beautiful,
that it's self-help.
It's empowerment.
It's harnessing the
entrepreneurial flair.
It's the triple bottom
line, bottom of the
pyramid, social business.
It touches all the right buttons
that we want to hear.
And it's just a nice story.
It's compatible with our
view of the world.
Competition is a good thing/
it's gonna bring about
wonderful outcomes.
We can solve all the world's
problems with this kind of
free market, neoliberal
economic strategy.
Not that it's doing particularly
well right now.
But I think, above all, there
was a sort of growing
discontent with traditional aid,
which is best summarized
[INAUDIBLE], don't give
the man a fish,
teach the man to fish.
It was this kind of normal aid
in the last century, people
were sort of getting
a bit tired of it.
It didn't seem to really
be working.
It wasn't so nice.
You're just giving away money.
So they were disillusioned.
There was a sudden
disillusionment with
traditional aid.
And then microfinance
came along.
And it was new.
And it was cool.
And it was kind of innovative.
And it harnessed all
these things.
And people were ready
for something new.
So they just jumped onto
the bandwagon.
The problem is that there's
no transparency.
There's no regulation
whatsoever.
When you make a loan in India,
there is actually no one
sitting there, protecting the
rights of the Indian client.
There are now, because they
were committing suicide.
And the Indian regulators
stepped in.
But when you make a loan in
these countries, there's no
one looking over the shoulder
of the poor
person, protecting them.
It's totally and utterly
unregulated.
Women are signing contracts
with their fingerprints,
because they can't
read and write.
And in the contract, they are
giving away all their rights.
You can come in, and you can
take the last piece of tin off
their roof.
And they agreed to it.
There is no one protecting
their interests.
In the US, who is regulating
the institutions that are
taking the money from
the general public?
No one.
There's absolutely no one.
If you think that because
Deutsche Bank is
SEC-regulated, that that means
Deutsche Bank Microcredit
Funds, someone's actually
looking over their shoulder
and actually investigating what
they're investing in in
India, in Mexico, in Bolivia,
in Nigeria, just dream on.
There's no regulation.
So I mean, it's not really a
huge surprise that we ended up
in this situation.
We then got this slightly
ridiculous thing going on in
the UK right now-- you know,
with the Libor scandal.
These people are tweaking the
interest rates by a hundredth
of a percent.
And everyone's up in
arms about this.
The whole European Union is now
saying, oh, Spain's gonna
have to pay 7% interest
a year.
And this is enough to actually
bankrupt the entire EU,
potentially.
And yet we expect the poor to
pay interest rates of 80%,
100%, 150%, 195%.
If you think about it, it's
completely ridiculous.
But the reason is that there's
massive profit to be made from
microfinance.
And this is the thing which
people are slightly
forgetting.
We think that making profit is
going to attract the new
investors, and that this is
going to result in a more
competitive market, and all
this sort of stuff.
We buy this ideology.
But let's not put the horse
before the cart.
The bottom line is, people
are being attracted to
microfinance because in
a totally unregulated
environment, they can make
extremely high returns.
This is the bottom line.
And I think the other reason why
we're in this mess is this
kind of soundbite culture
that has emerged.
There's massive marketing
campaigns promoting
microfinance.
We've got people like--
I don't know if you're aware of
Burson-Marstellar, the PR company.
Rachel Maddow in her
show summarized it.
She said, when evil needs PR,
evil has Burson-Marstellar on
speed dial.
These are the guys who did
Union Carbide, General
Pinochet, that favorite,
Big Tobacco.
Who else did?
All the bad dudes, the people
who did the Facebook smear
campaign against you guys,
I believe, that was
Burson-Marstellar.
These are the people who
are now defending the
microfinance sector.
They're working with
friends of Grameen.
There's this huge
kind of spin.
Oh, get images on to
people's screens.
Tell them we need another
500 pictures of
women with sewing machines.
This will make it
all blow over.
And people have limited
attention spans.
You know, they see these pieces
of bad news and they
go, oh well, it was on
"The Simpsons." The
guy got a Nobel Prize.
Oprah Winfrey interviewed them,
so it's probably OK.
I'll keep on giving the money.
No one's actually looking
into the details.
No one's actually stopping and
just saying, hang on, let me
just take stock of this.
Does this make sense?
What is the evidence?
And there's no one actually
answering the one key problem,
which is, it's not working.
I mean, you'd think that that
would attract some attention.
No.
Those sorts of conversations
are prohibited.
We're not allowed to talk about
the fact it doesn't
actually work.
So I think that sort of explains
maybe how we arrived
in this worrying situation.
The sector is now estimated
at about $70 billion.
It's 200 million clients now,
growing at a million a week,
or a million a month
or something.
And the microfinance community,
particularly the
investment community, has
got very clear goals.
We want to get to a billion.
There's a billion people
out there.
They all need a credit card.
They're all unregulated.
And hey, we can make some decent
profit out of them,
because we don't have these
annoying regulators that we
have in Europe and the United
States who are gonna actually
start exercising people's
rights.
So we can just charge them
whatever we want.
And there's a billion new
people to profit from.
So whistleblowing.
What happens when you blow the
whistle on an entire industry?
First of all, I can tell you,
it's deeply stressful.
This has been, I think, one
of the toughest six
months of my life.
The last month has
been total hell.
Thank god I'm actually leaving
in a few days, going home.
I can't wait to put this
all behind me.
Getting fired by the
entire sector--
the sector, it's slightly
unusual.
Because generally what they
do when whistleblowers--
there's been a couple of people
who have dared to
criticize it.
Usually they come out
guns blazing.
There's been a case of
academics having
their funding cut.
We've had two threats.
The second threat was on
our home phone number.
And we ended up moving house
shortly afterwards.
You get blacklisted
from conferences.
No one will reply
to your emails.
And it's weird, because on the
one hand, some friends, some
people that you believed were
friends, actually turn around
and stab you in the back, which
is a bit disappointing.
But the thing which is actually
really nice is that
I've had some really great
support from random people I
would never have thought of
calling up and saying, OK,
what can we do to
clean this up?
People that maybe I never
thought would actually dare to
come out and try to clean
up, they have.
I mean, it's been
very surprising.
The support has come from
unusual places.
And the betrayals have come
from unusual places--
sometimes quite disappointing,
to be honest.
But what's unusual about this
one, I think partly because of
the transparency, partly
because of the website,
because all the evidence is out
there, this whistleblowing
exercise has been slightly
different to former critics in
that the entire sector
has just gone silent.
No one has done anything.
I was in DC, which is home to
some of the people most
implicated in the book--
World Relief, Grameen
Foundation USA--
actually who Google supports,
just to mention it--
and Calvert Foundation.
I was expecting to have
eggs thrown at me.
In actual fact didn't, which
was rather nice.
And I think basically now the
sector is in just complete
lock-down mode.
No one's issuing a
press release.
No one's answering
phone calls.
No one's replying to emails.
It's just silence.
We don't want to give any
more oxygen to this.
We don't want anyone
to discuss this.
If we dare to actually
criticize the
book, on what grounds?
And then we're going to
get into a debate.
And it's going to be
put on the table.
And it's going to attract
attention.
So basically now the sector is
just saying, we've gotta hush
this up totally.
So I don't know.
I don't know really how to
explain the complete silence
of the people implicated
in the book.
I actually anticipated in
the book, these are the
traditional methods that they
use, the smear campaigns.
This is the way they normally
attack their critics.
These are the examples of
individual critics who have
been blacklisted and had these
campaigns against them.
And it hasn't happened.
So actually if you want to
criticize the book, that's a
good point to criticize.
I was completely wrong
on that one.
I don't know why it is.
I mean, the only thing that I
can consume is that their
lawyers have said, you know
what, there's no point in
defending this.
You're just gonna have to
let this blow over.
So what can we do?
How can we solve the problem?
I think the first thing
is transparency.
This is the most opaque, murky
sector that I believe exists
possibly on the planet,
certainly
within financial services.
When you do an investment,
when you get given that
photograph of the person you
supposedly invested in, when
you look at your microfinance
investment fund and they give
you the glossy brochure, I mean,
it's total pure spin.
There's absolutely no flow
of information from
the field to you.
It doesn't even exist.
Most of these banks don't even
know who they're lending to.
They don't even capture data
on their own clients.
So it's absolutely ridiculous
that, in America, they say, oh
yes, we've helped 2,463,914
female entrepreneurs.
They don't even know
if they're female.
They don't know if they're
entrepreneurs.
The evidence is that most of
them aren't doing anything
entrepreneurial whatsoever.
It's just total,
complete spin.
There's absolutely zero
regulation, like I say.
And until that changes,
there's going to be no
improvement.
The self-regulatory
bodies are--
what would you call it?
Endorsement without
enforcement.
If you want to get endorsed in
the microfinance sector as
being an ethical person who
adheres to the six client
protection principles
of microfinance--
protection of the client, fair
interest rates-- the only
thing you need to do to get
the endorsement to the
equivalent of a fair trade
coffee stamp on the back of
your coffee pot, you need
to have an email
address and a name.
Soon as you can do those two
things, you can then shove on
your website, we've endorsed
the Smart Campaign.
And then everyone goes,
oh, that's so nice.
So you must be treating your
clients well, wonderful.
I'll give you another
1,000 euros.
So self-regulation is
a complete joke.
And actual regulation
doesn't exist.
So that's just a couple
of little problems.
Now obviously the people who
are resisting any form of
regulation, no surprise who
they are, namely the
microfinance investment funds.
Those intermediaries that we are
hoping are acting in your
best interests and the best
interests of the poor are the
first people to say, no,
regulation is evil.
We have to have free markets.
Any kind of regulation
is gonna interfere
with the poor people.
And they're not going to
get as much money.
There is a wonderful case
in SKS recently.
I don't know if any of you are
aware of SKS, Vikram Akula,
very large Indian microfinance
institution which did an IPO a
couple of years ago.
14 times oversubscribed,
the biggest IPO in
microfinance history.
Made many people many
millions of dollars.
When the Indian government
started regulating them, the
share price fell 95%.
And a few days ago, there was
a lovely little news piece.
It said, SKS share price
increases by 50% as government
relaxes regulation.
There is an inverse
relationship.
More regulation, bad
for investors.
It means you're not gonna be
able to exploit the poor
people so much.
You're actually going to have
to do some sort of ethical
treatment of them.
You're not gonna be able
to charge them such
high interest rates.
And that's not very good
for investors.
I mean, the correlation
is quite uncanny.
There is already some increased
scrutiny coming from
regulators, which is
really encouraging.
I mean, I've already had
regulators calling me up and
saying, what can we do?
How do we do this?
Where do we need to be focusing
our attention?
So I mean, maybe there are
some good signs that the
regulators are stepping
up to the plate.
But until that happens, I remain
fairly pessimistic.
But I think one of the things
which is actually really
good-- and given that this is
Google, I think it's worth
mentioning this--
is, what is the role
of technology?
And actually, technology is
already having a big impact in
improving microfinance, and
could potentially have a much
bigger impact.
The last thing is I'm just gonna
touch on some of the
areas where technology's
having a good impact.
First of all, cloud-based
IT systems.
The software that these banks
use to operate their
operations is actually
surprisingly complicated.
You've got millions, high-volume
of transactions.
You've got interest and
capital repayments.
And it is actually surprisingly
complicated, just
because of the sheer volume.
And these people are repaying
their loans weekly, sometimes
even daily.
So you can imagine the actual
information flow is vast.
So IT problems in the field are
really difficult, because
you can't always
get good staff.
You've got problems of
computer viruses.
You don't have a very high level
of education in many of
the places.
So it's difficult to
really manage it.
Now you've got the
first cloud-based
systems are being operated.
And in fact, one of them--
I believe it's called Mambu,
in Germany-- is
hosted by you guys.
So this actually gives a way
not only for improved IT,
which means improved control,
which means less fraud, which
means more tracking of the
actual activities.
But it gives the investors in
the US and Europe, it gives
the regulators, it gives the
rating agencies a way to
actually look into what's
really going on in the
institution much more closely.
Obviously they need
permission.
But a bank can say to its
investors, give us a few
million dollars.
But what we'll do is we'll allow
you access to our IT
systems so you can
log in remotely.
And you can actually watch
what's happening.
And this is happening now.
I've been in the offices of
this company in Germany.
And you actually see
transactions
coming in in real time.
You see credit application
process being posted.
And you can actually see
who's regulating it.
Oh, that looks a bit dodgy.
I want to stop that
one right now.
This additional scrutiny
is a really good thing.
One of the things which we're
doing now is we're using--
I'm originally an
econometrician.
We're using some of the
econometrics and statistical
analysis that is traditionally
used by credit card companies
to analyze their portfolios and
work out characteristics
of well-performing clients,
poorly performing clients.
This kind of technology, which
is well-developed, we're now
using this in microfinance.
So combining that with
cloud-based IT systems is
potentially very,
very powerful.
So we're able to, for example,
analyze databases and see, OK,
these are the types of clients
who are actually really
benefiting from microfinance.
These people are actually
suffering from microfinance.
We can come up with very, very
precise suggestions on how the
bank can skew its entire
operations so that it's doing
more of the good microfinance
and less of the bad
microfinance.
And we can do this without
visiting the bank.
And if, as more institutions go
into cloud-based systems,
we get a bigger and bigger
data set, then we can
potentially do some very
interesting analysis.
So I mean, that's one
good example.
Obviously mobile technology
is the big
buzzword at the moment.
Poor people do now
have cell phones.
And increasingly they're
actually using smartphones as
the price has come down.
And it's cool to have
a smartphone.
Even if you can't afford to
put food on the table,
everyone wants a smartphone.
So a surprising number
of people have them.
So this originally was being
used for money transfers,
M-Pesa, the virtual money
in East Africa,
those sorts of things.
But actually now there's a bank
called Musoni, which is
the first completely virtual
microfinance institution,
based in Kenya.
And I think they do
operations in a
couple of other countries.
So they're actually a branchless
bank that does all
its loan disbursements, loan
repayments, completely and
utterly by cell phones.
Now the good thing about these
smartphones is that it's not
just that the poor can do
transactions on them and that
they can do them in a
much cheaper way.
The banks don't have to have big
branch networks and lots
of staff running around
collecting loans.
But it also is a way that we
can get information to the
poor people.
So for example, we're all used
to here, whenever you want to
buy something, you
go on to Google.
And you compare the prices.
And you can see where you
can get the best deal
for whatever it is.
Poor people need to be able
to shop around for
the interest rates.
Where is actually the best
place to get a loan?
And it sounds like a really
simple thing.
But that information is
not available to them.
Ironically, if you're sitting
in the US and you know where
to go, I can find out all the
information of the best
microfinance institutions in
Uganda for this particular
person, for this particular
purpose of loan.
I can work that out from here.
The problem is is that the poor
people don't have access
to that information.
As they start using phones,
they're gonna have
more access to this.
So that could potentially
have quite a big impact.
The use of mobile phones
and the use of improved
technology, it reduces the
fraud, because fraud in
microfinance is chronic.
And the ability to actually
track the flow of money right
actually from the source, right
the way through to the
audited statements, it makes
fraud a lot more difficult.
It doesn't make it impossible.
And accounting fraud is
still a big problem.
But it's definitely cleaning up
the act and holding people
more comfortable.
And one of the things
which we're doing--
I work with an institution
down in South America.
We're using GPS now.
So we use Google Maps.
And we can actually see, in
real time, where our loan
officers are.
We can track them.
We can optimize their routes to
go and visit their clients
so that they're not
wasting time.
Thank you very much for Google
Earth, by the way.
That was a really
good invention.
And we can also track.
If we see loan officers spending
too much time in a
certain region, we can literally
say, hang on, this
guy's in a bar.
That's not a client.
There might be a little alarm
bell ringing here.
Sometimes the loan officers
get a bit annoyed when we
point this out to them.
They say that we're
following them.
And we're like, yep.
And look, you can see.
You can follow yourself
if you want.
It's completely open.
Anyone can log in.
Another thing is
credit bureaus.
Historically, there weren't
really credit bureaus in
developing countries.
Now because they can get hold
of the technology relatively
easily, the software for
managing this vast quantity of
data, now institutions can log
in and see the credit history
of even very, very poor people
who are traditionally not even
mentioned in any part of
the formal sector.
And then the final thing is,
what we're doing now is we're
trying to launch a kind of
WikiLeaks-style support for
whistleblowers in the
microfinance sector.
And this is potentially a
very interesting thing.
Because people within the
microfinance community, we all
know that this is going on.
But it's very difficult.
If you try to complain in the
microfinance institution to
your boss-- you know, like, uh,
don't you think it's a bit
dodgy treating the women
this aggressively?
You just get fired.
The interest rates seem a bit
high, and we're telling our
investors that we're charging
36% interest rate.
But it's actually 136%.
There's some ethical questions
there maybe.
I'm not sure if this is
completely transparent.
You just get fired.
So what we're hoping now is that
now that there is enough
critical mass of people who are
willing to stand up and
criticize microfinance that we
can start capturing this data
directly from the people
within the microfinance
investment funds and the people
institutions on the ground,
where they have a way to
actually send us information.
And obviously we have
to check everything.
But as we start seeing patterns
emerging in certain
institutions, this can be like
the fuel that will tell us,
OK, this is where we need
to direct our attention.
We know journalists in these
different countries.
We can direct the journalists
to the right people.
And we can do this
anonymously.
So this is one element where
we're hoping to use technology
to actually improve
the sector.
By way of conclusion,
microfinance, it's not
working very well.
But it can work.
I really believe that
we can fix this.
I know a lot of really
good institutions.
Microfinance investment funds,
I'm hard-pressed to think of
one that is actually any good.
But maybe there's one or two.
And the lending platforms,
there are
one or two good ones.
But it does work.
The model is proven
to be working.
If you've got the right
incentive, if your goal is to
help poor people, and make a
modest amount of profit, then
you can do that.
And there are hundreds of
examples of it happening.
Unfortunately there
aren't 10,000
examples of it happening.
And it is the minority of cases
where it's working.
But I think we can fix it.
And I remain very optimistic.
But we need to start focusing
on poverty and not
on return on equity.
Return on equity will always
lead to high interest rates
and bad treatment
of the clients.
They go hand in hand.
There's no other way.
It's not an opinion.
It's a fact.
If you want to make more money
out of lending to someone, you
need to charge them a higher
interest rate.
And I guess my final concluding
statement is, if
you're going to invest in
microfinance, be very, very,
very careful, and ask really
penetrating questions to the
people that you're trusting
with your money.
Because otherwise you
will be duped.
Thank you.
And questions?
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Hugh will be glad
to take your questions.
Please step up to the mic so
the people at the remote
offices and on YouTube
can hear you.
AUDIENCE: Since I'm closest
to the microphone.
So a couple of weeks ago, we
had the founder of kiva.org
here, who gives a good talk.
And early in your discussion,
you said that there were quite
a few academic studies that said
microfinance doesn't work
or hasn't worked.
Did they indicate that it
doesn't work because the
system is just corrupt and
unregulated, but in theory it
could, as you sort
of mentioned in
your concluding statement?
HUGH SINCLAIR: If you
look at the academic
research, it's divided.
So there are a lot of papers
that say microfinance is a
great thing.
It's the miracle cure
for poverty.
And we've got all this
evidence to support
that it's the case.
There are lot of other papers
that say it's terrible.
It's hurting the poor.
So it's not to say that there's
no agreement at all.
It's a huge spectrum.
I mean, the two people in
particular, David Roodman and
Maren Duvendack, who are the
people who really, really
rigorously analyzed the entirety
of the sector, their
overall conclusion was that it
doesn't work, which is a lot
of people are actually doing
really good microfinance.
A lot of people are doing
really bad microfinance.
And on average, it
doesn't work.
That is the conclusion.
Now, I'm not an academic.
I haven't read the--
I mean, Maren Duvendack
read 2,836 papers.
I couldn't imagine worse than
getting through even 20 of
those papers.
But the problem isn't
necessarily because of
microeconomic problems that are
happening on the ground,
but also because of the
investment funds.
The people who are channeling
the money
have a twisted incentive.
They don't actually have an
incentive necessarily to seek
out the microfinance that does
work, because of this thing,
the principal-agent problem.
So I mean, a number of people
are now saying, OK, we need to
start focusing on the
flow of money.
Because just by looking down
here, there's just so much
complexity.
There's just so many--
what is it?
10,000 microfinance
institutions.
Each one is slightly
different.
Each one's doing something.
It's very difficult
to really ask why.
But common sense alone
is enough.
If you go into a market and you
say, OK, I'm gonna lend to
all the people on this side
of the room, you're
all gonna get loans.
So you get your loans
and you work hard.
And you're gonna have to work
very hard, because the first
100% return on your investment
is just to pay me interest.
But let's say that you work
even harder, even
harder, even harder.
Well, what about these guys?
They're just getting
crowded out.
They're just getting displaced,
because you're now
selling so many tomatoes that
these guys can't operate.
Now when you go to the academics
and you say, OK, let
me have a look at what are
your papers doing, until
recently, when they started
doing random control trials,
they tended to look only at this
side of the room, which
is, in a way, completely
flawed.
I mean, where is the increase
in aggregate demand?
If the total number of tomatoes
doesn't increase, it
doesn't really matter who's
benefiting, because it's a
zero-sum game at the
end of the day.
Now obviously you can increase
the demand if you lend to the
consumers, the consumer
finance.
But then you're creating a
completely artificial market.
You're lending money
to the suppliers.
And you're lending money
to the demanders.
And you create a big bubble.
And this is what we saw in the
Nicaragua, for example.
The funds just flooded in.
They pumped in, I think
it was $420 million.
And what was happening was
the loans were just being
recycled, one after the other,
after the other.
The suppliers were often
also the demanders.
Everyone was operating on both
sides of the market.
And this huge credit bubble
was just created, and just
inflated more and more and more
and more, without any
regulatory oversight,
as usual.
And eventually what happened?
You had 30 people just said, two
banks tried to imprison 30
people in the north
of Nicaragua, in
Jalapa, I think it was.
And they put them in prison.
And they said, you didn't
repay your loans.
So you're going to prison.
And their families rebelled.
Then everyone in the
community rebelled.
region rebelled.
And then it spread right the
way across Nicaragua.
And it became a movement
called No Pago--
I'm not gonna pay.
And you had just a grassroots
movement of the so-called
beneficiaries of microfinance
just turning around and
saying, you guys came in
here 10 years ago.
You told us you were gonna
get us out of poverty.
The fact of the matter
is, none of us
have got out of poverty.
We were meant to be protected
by the government with laws
about the maximum interest
rates being 20%, 25%.
You're charging us 60%,
70%, 80% interest.
No one's actually benefiting
from this.
And we're not gonna
pay you anymore.
And the entire thing
collapsed.
And the microfinance community
was like, hmm, this is a bit
embarrassing, because it was
caused by our own people, the
people that we've been slapping
up on websites all
these years with sewing
machines, saying that these
people are just so eternally
grateful to us for us being so
generous as to give them a loan
at 60% interest a year.
They've now bitten us.
That's what happens when
you lend to both
sides of the market.
It's just a false market.
AUDIENCE: Can you say something
about microsavings
as opposed to microcredit?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah,
microsavings is like the
forgotten side of the
entire equation.
And I mean, I'm a big supporter
of microsavings,
because the great thing is, the
poor, it's not that they
just don't have access
to credit.
It's also that they just have
no safe way where they can
deposit their money and maybe
earn a small interest rate,
just to cover inflation.
That's all that's necessary.
So there are institutions which
focus exclusively in
microsavings, which is good.
And there are also institutions
which are
microfinance banks.
So they do the lending.
And they also have savings.
It's more difficult with savings
for two reasons.
One is that you need
to be regulated.
Even in these developing
countries, there are much
stricter rules about taking
money from the general public
than giving money to the general
public, which is good.
It should be like that.
So a lot of institutions are
kind of hesitant to get into
savings, because it's
really difficult.
You have to be regulated.
People are going to start asking
awkward questions.
And you're gonna have to submit
data to a central bank,
which is going to mean that
you can't do certain
activities.
In a way, it's much easier to
operate as an unregulated NGO
just doing credit.
The other problem with savings
is that they're not profitable
for investors.
No one can actually make any
money out of an institution
that is just taking money from
the poor and safekeeping it.
So there's a kind of incentive
to not get into it.
Now there are people doing it.
An I applaud it.
I think it's the way ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess from
the perspective of, if you
wanted to help the poor,
then it sounds like
microsavings is better.
And if you're willing to do,
like, matching funds or
something like that, it
seems like that--
if you're OK with losing money,
essentially, if you
were going to generate the
money anyways, then
microsavings seems like
a better option.
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
about this data on the
website, Microfinance
Transparency.
How is a process starting
to collect this data?
I assume that at some point,
you have to start recording
phone calls and so on.
So when did that get started?
When did you start thinking
about it?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah, I sort
of describe it in
the book to an extent.
I saw a couple of pretty
nasty frauds.
And then when I tried to
actually do something about
it, I realized, you know what,
damn, I don't actually have
the data, the proof.
And now that I've raised the
alarm bell, now it's too late
for me to go in and try
and get the data.
So what I did, when I was
working at this investment
fund in Europe, when I started
realizing, uh-oh, hang on,
there's some nasty stuff going
on, I learned from the
previous mistakes.
And I basically just kept
quiet and just started
secretly gathering all the data
over, yeah, it was about
a year, I guess.
And then when I confronted
the management of this
institution, I was fired, went
to court, won a court case
against them.
And then I was working
as a consultant.
But to an extent, that
was still kept
relatively hushed up.
People didn't put two
and two together.
So I was still able to work
with a number of these
institutions, bizarrely, because
the communication in
the sector was pretty poor
at the best of times.
So I was able to lure them
into conversations.
And we were able to do things
like, for example, we would
make an investment in one of
these funds in the EU.
So we were protected by
a European regulator.
Do an investment simply
to then be
protected by the regulator.
[INAUDIBLE]
investment bank, issue a
formal complaint to the
regulator, and then
go to the AGM.
This was another good trick.
Do an investment.
It doesn't matter.
Even if you've just go $1
invested in the company, the
company, by law, has to
invite you to the AGM.
You have the right
to go to the AGM.
So then you can go to the AGM.
And you can stand up and
you can ask a really
embarrassing question.
So it was all planned.
It was just a long strategy of,
OK, let's for this one,
then this one, then this
one, then this one.
And there was a group
of people.
I mean, I didn't
work on my own.
I had a lot of support.
AUDIENCE: What was it?
How long did it take?
How long did this
process take?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Well, I mean, it
wasn't like, OK, now I've
finished gathering
the data, now we
start blowing the whistle.
But I mean, really, it started
in about 2007.
And I guess the book doesn't
really go beyond 2011.
So it was about four years.
But I was individually blowing
the whistle in certain ways
during that period.
But only now I can't get
any phone calls.
Now I can't get any more data.
Now it's over.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask, how
are the mechanisms enforced?
How do they enforce repayment
of loans?
And another question is,
how do you actually
estimate risk in this?
I mean, typically when you make
an investment, you're
balancing risk versus reward.
And I think the 2008 fiasco
showed us that nobody was able
to estimate risk.
And in this particular case, it
seems even more difficult
to estimate risk.
So what kind of work is
being done on that?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah.
The enforcement of loans, yeah,
there's 1,000 different
ways that people do it.
The famous one is the group
lending, so group liability.
So if one person defaults, the
other people in the group have
to step up to the plate.
You also have forced savings,
which is pretty unethical.
But a lot of institutions do
it, where in order to get a
loan, you're forced
to make a deposit.
So effectively, you're
collateralizing your own loan.
Then also, just in the
contracts, they'll just have
clauses which say, we can come
and take away your pots and
pans and your whatever.
In the case of India, what you
had in terms of getting loans
repaid was such aggressive and
threatening practices that,
actually, in the 54
suicide cases--
actually it was 53 suicides
and one murder--
you just had women who they just
were in total despair.
The loan officers would hound
them, hound them, humiliate
them, sit outside their houses
and embarrass them in front of
their neighbors, and just keep
on, just keep driving them
down, driving them down, driving
them down, until
eventually, once they've given
up all their assets and
they've got nothing left,
eventually they just killed
themselves.
With regards to risk, I mean,
there's all sorts of different
levels that you have
to look at.
I mean, are you talking about
the risk for an investor?
Also has additional risks,
in addition to just
non-repayment of loans--
you have things like foreign
exchange risk.
You have capital controls.
Maybe you invest in a country.
Say, for example, you had
invested in Argentina.
Now what you're seeing is it's
getting very difficult to get
money in and out of Argentina.
So you've got the additional
risks from an investor's
perspective.
But on the ground level, one
thing that is true is when
people talk about the credit
risk of the poor.
It's actually really good.
I mean, the statistics of the
98% repayment rates are true.
They are true.
I mean, it tends to
be quite extreme.
It's either 97%, 98%, 99%
repayment rates, very, very
good repayment rates.
Or it's a meltdown.
There's not a lot really
in between.
So when you get to Nicaragua,
suddenly you get
30% repayment rates.
But in general, the
poor repay.
In fact, when you look at who's
the better credit risk,
I haven't seen any data, but
I think it would be rather
interesting to see, what is
the repayment rate of Mali
compared to the United
States right now?
I wouldn't be surprised to see
that there are a number of
developing countries that are
actually less risky than the
US and Europe.
MALE SPEAKER: Hugh, we
talked about this
a little bit before.
A lot of people here are
interested in Kiva, including
some very wealthy people
that I know.
Could you say a few
words about that?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah, Kiva gets
10 pages in the book.
I particularly focus on Kiva.
I can't go into all the detail
here, because it's very subtle
things that are happening at
Kiva with regards, did the
money actually go to that
particular person?
There are a lot of question
marks about that.
There was the issue in the "New
York Times" about Kiva
post-financing transactions.
So when you lend on Kiva, your
money isn't actually going to
that person.
That person has already had
a loan six months ago.
Essentially what you're doing
is you're buying the
loan off the bank.
You're post-financing it.
Now obviously you take
the full credit risk.
And for all you know, the person
is already in default,
which raises an ethical
question there.
Maybe I would like to know at
least if the person is already
defaulting on the loan.
But then the other question
is, what are the interest
rates that--
not Kiva.
Kiva doesn't charge interest.
Kiva gives the money to the
microfinance institutions.
They then take this
interest-free capital that
they don't take any of the
credit risk, and they go and
lend it out to institutions at
rates which some people would
consider extortionate.
Because the microfinance sector
doesn't dare define
extortionate, you can never say
that it is extortionate,
because there's no definition.
The highest one at the
moment is BRAC in
Sudan, which is 88%.
In Mexico, they tend
to be in the 80s.
And if you say to Kiva, just
answer me one question.
You've given me the photo
of the woman.
I know she's getting a goat.
You told me about her children,
her little story,
her hopes and aspirations, and
how much money she wants, and
how long, and what's she
gonna do with it.
And you can give me all
this information.
It can come from the other side
of Mongolia all the way
to my little computer
in California.
But there's no interest rate.
Could you tell me what
the interest rate is?
They can't tell you.
They can't or they
won't tell you.
I believe it's that actually
they can't.
So they'll fob you off with a
thing called the portfolio
yield, which is the interest
rate that the institution, on
average, charges last year
or the year before.
And they get that data from a
place called the MIX Market,
which is self-submitted data.
So the bank gives the data.
A couple of years later, it gets
into the Kiva website.
And Kiva say, that's a kind of
rough proxy of the actual
interest rate.
That's as close as
they get to it.
Now the problem is is that
portfolio yield is one of the
easiest statistics to
manipulate, legally manipulate
under the accounting laws of
most countries, because of the
subtleties of how it's
actually calculated.
And I have personally
manipulated portfolio yields,
I'm ashamed to say.
It's a really easy
one to go for.
It's also the one statistic
that all the microfinance
institutions are very
sensitive about.
They want to get that down as
low as possible, because they
know that people raise an
eyebrow when you see portfolio
yields of 125%.
It's such an emotive topic that
they just do everything
they can to reduce it.
And it's very easy
to reduce it.
So if you just ask one question
to Kiva, for me,
that's the question to ask, is
why won't you tell me the
interest rate of the loan that
I made to that person?
But the fundamental question
about Kiva for me is-- and in
the book, I go through
all the 990 reports.
And you can see the buffer
accounting Kiva, which is, I
think, currently it's about
$40 million sitting in an
account in California, in
Wells Fargo, California.
And who earns interest
on that money?
Remember when you clicked I
Accept on the user acceptance
thing, and you forgot to read
paragraph 89 of page 412,
subsection E9?
All the interest earned in the
buffer account accumulates to
Kiva, of course.
Now is $42 million a large
buffer account to have for a
company that's actually doing
about $60 million to $70
million a year?
I don't know.
I think it sounds like quite
a big buffer to me.
But I don't pass any judgment.
I just say I could do it
on a smaller buffer.
But the question is this.
Who is Kiva for?
Who are the beneficiaries
of Kiva?
This is my question
to them, is Kiva
trying to help the poor?
Or is Kiva trying to give a
nice feeling to people in
America, to feel like
I've done something?
It's like the child
sponsorship.
It's like, here I am
in California.
There's all this suffering in
the world, I believe in free
markets and entrepreneurship
and everything.
But what am I gonna do?
I can't do anything.
So huh, I can just do $25
on my Paypal account.
And I can get this nice fluffy
feeling inside that I helped
this woman buy a goat
or a sewing machine.
I've got a photo to prove it.
And then I just feel better
about myself.
So my question is, who is
the beneficiary of Kiva?
I don't think it's
the poor at all.
I think it's you guys.
AUDIENCE: There was big news in
the last year that Facebook
had an IPO and raised a
tremendous amount of capital,
presumably, to fund future
development of their business.
I recently heard from two
googlers about that principle
being applied at a smaller
scale, where very small
startups can raise on the order
of $100,000 or $250,000,
which sort of resembles the
difference in microfinance
that we would typically
refer to.
But there's also the scale of,
say, someone who wants to open
a pizza shop in the US.
And they want to raise
$20,000 in order to
get started on that.
So I'm wondering, what is the
difference between raising
capital at the very large
level versus this
microfinance level?
How should we think about the
difference in these to
accomplish a social good of
prosperity for a group of
individuals?
HUGH SINCLAIR: Well, first of
all, I would say that this
label, "microfinance," is
actually ridiculous in a way.
Microfinance is just banking.
It's nothing more sophisticated
than banking.
We're just doing it in bigger
volumes to poorer people at
higher interest rates.
So I don't think that you can
say, here's the formal banking
sector of developed countries,
and now we've
got this new thing.
It's not new at all.
The difference what you're
referring to is
this debt and equity.
Those are two very
fundamentally different things.
Now when you start raising
equity, it has a whole
different risk-reward profile.
So I think that saying that
microfinance could be used for
equity, maybe here that
could happen.
But the idea of having
shareholder agreements and all
this sort of stuff in the
developing world is, in
practice, probably not going
to happen for 100 years.
But I don't know, sorry.
I mean, does that answer
your question?
I'm not sure if I--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
I need to interrupt.
AUDIENCE: Basically,
it's banking.
HUGH SINCLAIR: Yeah,
This is just banking, good-old
fashioned banking.
We've been doing it
for 1,000 years.
Now we're just doing
it to the poor.
There shouldn't be this aura
about microfinance.
And actually, when you get the
mainstream banks doing a thing
called downscaling and moving
into the microfinance area, in
a way that might be one of the
most sensible ways to do it.
Instead of setting up dedicated
microfinance
institutions, actually just
saying, let's just get the
banks to go deeper
into the market.
And that is happening already.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's thank
Hugh for coming here.
HUGH SINCLAIR: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]